Hello there I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're the Slow Mo Guys
and we're here in the Nevada Desert.
You know, as you do, you just
stand in the desert don't ya?
Nothing here so.
Nothing going on.
It's a great place to fire guns.
Great place to fire guns.
Guns in slow mo, always great.
Big thanks to EA for
sponsoring this video.
We're here to promote "Battlefield 1".
Dan, what do you like
about the first World War,
the Great War?
It's the amount of tech that was made.
As a kid I never
understood how they managed
to do the thing where
they fired machine guns
through the propellers of planes.
I just didn't understand it.
The old sync gear.
Yeah, and now I'm a grown-up
and I thought, you know,
the internet has been invented
I'm gonna have to look it up,
and they have something called
sync gear like you said,
where the bullets managed
to just go in between the propellers,
and so they could fly the plane
and shoot where they're looking at
as opposed to trying to control a gun
and the plane at the same time,
which I imagine is really hard.
Well it's very difficult
to find a World War I plane
that still shoots live ammo
through its own propeller,
but thankfully we've been able to
recreate exactly that with this device,
and we're gonna film it
at extremely high speeds.
I whipped this up last night,
I can't wait to get on it.
You made this, did you?
Yeah, yeah I made it with a
hammer, screwdriver, spanner.
Phillip's head?
Yeah, yeah Phillip's head.
And a number two monkey wrench.
Number three actually.
Number three.
Yeah.
All right well let's take
a look at this thing.
I'm in.
That's a funny sight.
I think I'm too short for this thing.
Were they taller in
World War I or something?
Well I don't think they were
on tip-toes like-
I can't imagine this being
the most comfortable thing in the world.
Fred Flintstone through the bottom, love.
It was World War I, I
don't know these things,
they might've done.
What gun is this then?
Oh so this is a Vickers
machine gun from World War I.
Authentic stuff.
I mean, in actual fact we
couldn't get hold of one of those
so we turned an M60 upside down
and stuck one of these bad boys on it
and the heat sync to make it look cool.
Which it does.
I'm happy with it.
I like the sound of an M60.
Well I've only shot them in video games,
but it's always like .
It is meaty isn't it?
That was some majestic looking footage.
I love how it's so close to the propeller.
The bullet's going past it like here.
It's like how last minute
can we fire the bullet so it right by.
Oh man.
And it's amazing when we're
on the 25/11 at 120,000 FPS,
it pretty much just pauses the propeller.
Yeah, this is moving fast, right,
so then in your eyes it's moving rapidly,
but the bullet is just
moving in order of magnitude
that's just way faster.
Yeah so this is like hovering in the air
and that's like .
Yeah look we could've just
stopped this to be honest
and just be like yeah,
bang, sweet, shot done.
You know what though?
What?
I'm pretty sure 90 percent
of the audience watching
this are thinking-
I know what you're thinking.
Well what happens if it hits right?
Yeah, yeah.
So we could de sync, we
could turn off the sync gear,
so that instead of just
shooting at the right time
we just unload with the
machine gun completely
and hopefully by chance
we'll get it hitting through
the propeller just trashing it.
Just sort of like go for
it and see what happens.
See you later.
Oh man, imagine landing
like, successful mission,
and you're just like .
Oh man!
You just park it like, another job-
All right well let's de sync it.
Let's de sync the sync gear.
Yeah, let's do it.
Flip!
Flipping heck.
So we took off the sync gear
and looks like we got four hits.
Yeah judging by the high speed,
one went straight through the hole
that was already made by a previous one.
So it's one, two, three,
and then a little nick there is four.
Oh flip!
Ooh!
You can fry an egg.
Yeah, flipping hot.
Well, we learned that if
you keep your propeller
around 200 RPM it can survive
a couple bullets through it.
Yeah, I mean normally
when you're flying one of these things
they go around at 1,200 RPM.
Well we couldn't, we had
to tone it down a little.
Well if we had that kind
of speed on the ground
it would just start
juttering along the floor
and taking off.
Hard to focus on a moving plane.
Yeah.
Well hopefully you enjoyed
that video, I certainly did.
I found it very interesting.
Feel free to follow us on Twitter,
buy a shirt.
We've got a second channel,
and most importantly today,
make sure you check out "Battlefield 1".
I actually pre downloaded
it on my PC over there.
I have too, should we go
and play it over there?
Yeah, in the desert.